SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, last time we were
talking about this thing
called the theorem
of irrelevance.
At one level, the theorem of
irrelevance is just another
statement of, when you start
looking at detection theory,
there are things called
sufficient statistics.
And what the theorem of
irrelevance says is you can
ignore things that aren't part
of a sufficient statistic.
But more specifically, it says
something about what those
irrelevant things are.
And in particular, let me repeat
what we said last time
but with a little less
of the detail.
You start out with
a signal set.
Ok?
You're going to transmit one
element of that single--
signal set--
and you're going to turn
it into some waveform--
which we'll call X of t.
And X of t is going to depend
on which particular signal
enters the transmitter
at this point.
You're going to receive
something where the thing that
you receive has noise
added to it.
And also if you'll notice I've
written the thing that we
receive that it's including a
whole lot of other stuff.
OK?
In other words, the signal is
constrained to j different
degrees of freedom.
And what you get out of the
channel involves a much larger
set of degrees of freedom.
In other words, you're putting
things in involving only a
certain period of time, in a
certain bandwidth, usually.
And you can look at anything
you want to at the output.
The only thing is you can't peek
at what the input was at
the transmitter, because if
you could there will be no
sense in actually
transmitting it.
OK, so the point is, we receive
something which, in
the degrees of freedom that we
know about, Yj is equal Xj
plus the noise variables.
And in the other degrees
of freedom, Yj is
just equal to Zj.
And now the rules of the game
are that these out of band
things, all of these noise
coefficients, which are not
part of the phi 1 up to phi sub
capital J. All of these
things, the noise there, is
independent of the noise in--
is independent of the noise and
the signal in what we're
actually sending.
Because it's independent it's
irrelevant that's relatively
easy to show.
But the broader way to look at
this, and the way I want--
and the way I'd like to get
you used to thinking about
this-- is that this other stuff
here can include signals
sent by other users.
It can include signals sent
by you at other times.
It can include anything
else in the world.
And what this theorem is saying
is, if you're sending
the signal in just these j
degrees of freedom, then you
don't have to look
at anything else.
So that all you have to look
at is these received
components, Y sub j.
OK, it says something
more than that.
It says a lot more than that.
These actual orthonormal
functions that you use, phi 1
up to phi sub capital
J, don't appear in
that solution at all.
OK?
In other words, you really
have a vector
problem at this point.
You have a j dimensional
vector that you send.
You have a j dimensional vector
that you receive.
You can use orthonormal
functions, which are anything
in the world, so long as the
noise in that region that
you're looking at and sending
things in does not vary.
In other words, what
you can send is
very broadband signals.
You can send very narrow
band signals.
You can send anything and it
doesn't make any difference.
What this says is when you're
dealing with a white Gaussian
noise channel, all signals
are equivalent.
OK?
In other words, it doesn't
make any difference what
modulation system you use.
They all behave the same way.
The only difference between
different modulation systems
comes in these second order
affects, which we haven't
started to look at much yet.
How hard is it to retrieve
carrier?
How hard is it to deal
with things like time
synchronization?
How hard is it to build
the filters?
How hard is it to move from
passband down to baseband if
you want to do your operations
at baseband?
All of these questions become
important, but the basic
question of how to deal with the
Gaussian noise, it doesn't
make any difference.
You can use whatever system you
want to, and the analysis
of the noise part of the problem
is exactly the same at
everything.
OK?
And that's fairly important
because it says that in fact,
this signal space there
we're using--
I mean yes, we're all used
to the fact that
it's a vector space.
L2 is a vector space, fine--
what's important here is
you're using a finite part of
that vector space, and you can
deal with it just as if it's
finite dimensional vectors.
You can deal with vectors and
matrices and all of that neat
stuff and you can forget about
all of the analog stuff.
you look at 99 percent of the
papers appear both in the
information theory transactions
and in the
transactions of--
oh I guess it--
it's communication technology.
You look at all of these things
and 99 percent of the
authors don't know anything
about analog communication.
All they've learned is how to
deal with these vectors.
OK?
So in fact this is
the key to that.
And you can now play
their game.
But also when their game doesn't
work you can go back
to looking at the analog
waveforms.
But you now understand
what that game is
that they're playing.
They're assuming white
Gaussian noise.
They don't have to deal with
the fact that the white
Gaussian noise is spread over
all time and all frequency.
Because part of this thoerem
says it doesn't make any
difference how the noise is
characterized outside of this
region that you're looking at.
That's the other part of the
argument that we've been
dealing with all along.
It doesn't matter how you
model the noise anywhere
outside of what you're
looking at.
The only thing you need is that
the noise is independent
outside of there.
OK?
So that's--
I mean this was sort of trivial
analytically, but it's
really an important aspect
of what's going on.
OK.
Let's go back to QAM or PAM.
The baseband input to a white
Gaussian noise channel-- we're
going to model it as u of t--
we're going to look
at a succession
of j different signals.
In other words, when we study
detection, we said we're going
to build the system, we're going
to send one signal, and
then we're going to receive that
signal and we're going to
tear that system down.
We're not going to send more
than just this one signal.
OK, now we're sending a
big batch of signals.
Were sending capital
J of them.
Where J can be as big
as you please.
Now we're going to look at two
different alternatives.
OK, one of these alternatives
is sending all j signals and
building a receiver which
looks at all J of them
together and makes a joint
decision on everything.
It makes a maximum likelihood
decision on this sequence of J
possible inputs.
This is one of the things
we've looked at.
This is what happens when you
have non binary detection.
I mean, here you have an
enormous number of things
you're detecting between.
And you do maximum likelihood
detection on it.
And the question is, do you get
anything extra from that
beyond what you get out of doing
what we did before, just
forgetting about the fact that
other signals existed?
Namely, which is better?
What the notes prove, and what
I'm going to sort of indicate
here without any attempt
to prove it--
I mean it's not a hard
proof, it's just--
I mean the hardest part of this
is realizing what the
problem is.
And the problem is you
can detect things in
two different ways.
You can detect things one
signal at a time.
Or you can detect them the
whole sequence at a time.
And you do something different
in each of these cases.
OK, so we're going to assume
again that these thetas are an
orthonormal set.
I'm going to assume that
I've extended them so
they span all of l2.
I'm going to let v be a
sample of this output
vector, v1 to v sub j.
You see, I use the theorem of
irrelevance here because I
don't care about anything
beyond v sub j.
Because all those other
things are irrelevant.
So I only look at
v1 to v sub j.
So the little v is going
to be a sample value
of this random vector.
And the components of the random
vector, the output, are
going to be the input variables
plus the noise variables.
And the zj here are
independent.
I don't even have to
assume that they're
Gaussian for this argument.
They can be anything at all,
so long as they're
independent.
OK, now if I'm doing the signal
by signal detection, in
other words if what I'm doing is
I'm saying, "OK, I want to
take this little j signal, and I
want to decide on what it is
just from looking at the v
sample of the output." OK, I
can do that.
My observation is v sub j.
That's something we've
talked about.
I mean the fact that you might
have other information
available doesn't make
any difference.
You still can make a
detection on the
basis of this one variable.
OK, so we do that.
Now, we want to compare that
with what happens when we make
a detection for all capital J
of these inputs, conditional
on the whole sequence.
OK, you write out the
likelihood ratio.
It factors.
And the thing that happens when
you do this-- and you
have to read the notes for
the details on this,
and it's not hard--
what you find is that the
maximum likelihood decision is
exactly the same
in both cases.
OK, so it doesn't make any
difference whether you detect
little u sub j from the
observation v sub j.
Or whether you detect the
vector, u sub capital j, from
the whole set of outputs, v sub
1 up to v sub capital J.
You get the same answer
in both cases.
Now, you might say, "What
happens if some of these
likelihood ratios come out to
be right on the borderline,
equal to one?" Well it doesn't
make any difference because
that's a zero probability
thing.
If you want to worry about that,
you can worry about it
and you get the same answer, you
just have to be a little
more careful.
Now here is something the notes
don't say, and it's also
fairly important.
Here we're talking about the
case where all these signals
are independent of each other.
Which is sort of what we want
to look at in communication
because for the most part what
we're doing is we're taking
data of some sort, we're source
processing it to make
the bits coming up the channel
be independent of each other,
and then we're going
to be sending them.
Well except now we want to say,
well suppose that these
inputs are not independent.
Suppose, for example, that we
pass them through an error
correction encoding device
before transmitting them.
And the question is,
what happens then?
Well the trouble is then you
have dependence between
u1 and u sub j.
So you can still detect each
of these just by looking at
the single output.
And it's a maximum likelihood
detection based on that
observation.
But if you look at the entire
observation, v1 up to v sub
capital j, you get
something better.
How do I know you got
something better?
Well I know you get something
better because in this case
where u1 up to u sub j are
dependent on each other, these
output variables, v sub 1 up to
v sub capital j, depends on
each other.
They aren't irrelevant.
If you want to do the best
job of maximum likelihood
detection, given the observation
of v sub 1 up to v
sub capital j, then you're
going to use all those
variables in your detection
and you're going to
get a better --
And you're going to get
a better decision.
In other words, a smaller error
probability, then you
would have gotten otherwise.
OK?
But the important thing that
comes out of here is that this
simple minded decision--
where you make a decision on u
sub 1 based just on v sub 1--
it's something you can do.
You can do the maximum
likelihood decision.
And you know how it behaves.
You can calculate what the
error probability is.
But you know now automatically
that your error probability is
going to be greater than or
equal to the error probability
that you would get if you base
that decision one the whole
set of inputs.
OK, this is an argument
that, it seems hard
for most people to--
that it seems hard for most
people to think of right at
the beginning.
Which is really to say, if
you're doing an optimal
detection, it is optimal.
In other words, anything else
that you do is worse.
And you can always count on
that to get bound between
probabilities of error that
you get doing something
stupid, and probabilities of
error that you get doing
something intelligent.
And the stupid thing is
not always stupid--
I mean the stupid thing
is sometimes better
because it's cheaper--
but the error probability is
always worse there then if you
did the actual optimum thing.
OK, so people in fact often do
do detection where they have
coded systems.
They decode each received symbol
separately based on the
corresponding observation.
They wind up with
a larger error
probability than they should.
Then they pass this through
some kind of, some kind of
error correction device.
And they wind up with a system
that sort of performs
reasonably.
And you ask, "Well, would it
have performed better if in
fact what you did was to wait to
make a final decision until
you got all the data?"
And we talk a little bit about
various kinds of error control
later when we get
into wireless.
We'll see that some kinds of
coding systems can behave very
easily and can make use of all
this extra information.
And other ones can't.
Algebraic kinds of schemes can't
seem to make use of the
extra information.
And various other kinds of
schemes can make use of it.
And if you want to understand
what's happened in the error
correction field over the last
five years-- unfortunately
6.451 won't be given,
so you won't get all
the details of this--
but the simplest one sentence
statement you can say is that
the world has changed from
algebraic coding techniques to
probablistic decoding
techniques.
And the primary reason for it is
you want to make use of all
that extra information you get
from looking at the full
observation, rather than just
a partial observations.
OK.
Now, back to various
signal sets.
I put this slide up last time.
I want to really talk about it
this time because for each
number of degrees of freedom,
you can define what's called
an orthogonal code.
And the orthogonal codes for m
equals 2 and for m equals 3
are drawn here.
For m equals 2, it's something
that we've seen before.
Namely, if you want to send a
zero, you send a one in the
first compound, the first degree
of freedom, a zero in
the second.
And if you want to send a one,
you send the opposite thing.
We've all seen that this isn't
a very sensible thing to do
when we looked at binary
detection, because when you
use a scheme like this of course
the thing that happens
is we now know that we should
look at this in terms of just
looking at this line
along here.
Because what we're really
transmitting is a pilot tone,
so to speak, which is half way
in the middle here, which
sticks right here.
Plus something that
varies from that.
So that when we take out this
pilot tone, what we wind up
with is a one dimensional
system instead of a two
dimensional system.
Which we used to call antipodal
communication-- and
which everybody with any
sense calls antipodal
communication, even now--
but in terms of this, it's
the simplest case
of a simplex code.
And a simplex code is simply
an orthogonal code where
you've taken the mean
and moved it out.
And as soon as you remove the
mean from an orthogonal code,
you get rid of one degree
freedom, because one of the
signals becomes dependent
on the others.
Which is exactly what's
happened here.
You've just--
if all your signals are in one
degree of freedom here, when
you do the same thing down
here, well you get this.
And I'll talk about
that later.
So, one thing you can do from an
orthogonal code is go to a
simplex code.
The other thing you can do if
you want to transmit one more
bit out of this signal set is to
go to a bi orthogonal code.
Which says-- along with
transmitting zero, one and
one, zero-- you look this and
you say, "Gee why don't I also
put in zero minus one, minus
one zero, and zero
minus one down here.
Which is exactly what the
bi orthogonal code is.
The bi orthogonal code simply
says take your orthogonal code
and every time you have a one,
change it into a minus one and
get an extra code
word out of it.
What's the difference between
a set of code words and a
signal set?
Anybody have any idea?
Absolutely none.
They're both exactly
the same thing.
And you think of it as being a
code, usually, if what you're
doing is thinking of generating
an error correcting
code and then from that error
correcting code you think of
using QAM or PAM or something
else out beyond that.
You call it a signal set if
you're just doing the whole
thing as one unit.
What a lot of systems now do is
they start out with a code,
then they turn this into an
orthogonal signal set.
I'll tell you in other words.
A code produces bits.
From the bits you group them
together into sets of bits.
From the sets of bits you
go into a signal--
which is, for example something
from one of these
three possibilities here--
OK.
The important thing to notice
here-- and it's particularly
important to think about it for
a few minutes-- is because
you do so many exercises.
And you've done a number of them
already and you will do a
few more in this course
where you deal with
the m equals 2 case.
And you can deal with this
biorthogonal set here.
You can shift the biorthogonal
set around by 45 degrees.
In which case it looks
like this.
OK, so that looks like
two PAM sets.
It looks like a standard QAM.
It looks like standard 4QAM.
This is exactly the same
as this of course.
When you do detection on this
you do detection by saying,
when you transmit this does
the noise carry you across
that boundary?
And then does the noise carry
you across this boundary?
The noise in this direction is
orthogonal from the noise in
this direction and therefore,
finding the probability of
error is very, very simple.
Because because you look at two
separate orthogonal kinds
of noise and you can just
multiply these probabilities
together in the appropriate
way to
find out what's happening.
The important thing to have
stick in your memory now is
that as soon as you
go to m equals
three, life gets harder.
In fact, if you look at this
orthogonal set here and you
try to find the error
probability for it-- you try
to find it exactly--
you can't do it like this.
You can't just multiply
three terms.
You look at these regions in
three dimensional space.
If you want to visualize what
they are, what do you do?
What picture do you look at?
You look at this picture.
OK?
Because this picture is just
this with the mean taken away.
So the error probability here
is the same as the error
probability here.
When I send this point the
regions that I'm looking at
look like this.
And they're not orthogonal
to each other.
So to find the probability that
this point gets outside
of this region looks just
a little bit messy.
And that happens for all
m bigger than two.
I never knew this because well,
I think this is probably
a disaster that happens more
to teachers than to people
working in the field.
Because so often I have
explained to people how these
two dimensional pictures work
that I just get used to
thinking that this is
an easy problem.
And in fact when you start
looking at the problem for m
equals three, then the problem
gets much more interesting and
much more useful and much more
practical when n becomes three
or four or five or six
or seven or eight.
Beyond eight it becomes a
little too hard to do.
But up until there,
it's very easy.
OK, so we're going to make use
of that in a little bit.
As we said orthogonal codes
and simplex codes-- if you
scale the simplex code from
the orthogonal code-- have
exactly the same error
probability.
In other words, this code here
where I've made the distances
between the point square root
of two over two, which
corresponds to the distance
between the points here.
This and this have exactly the
same error probability.
So you can even, in fact, find
the error probability for this
or for this, whichever
you find easier.
You now think it's easier
to find the error
probability for this.
I've lead you down the primrose
path, because in fact
this one is easier to find the
error probability for.
This one, again, you
can find the error
probability if you want.
But the energy difference
between this and this is
simply the added energy that you
have to use here to send
the mean of these
three signals.
And one signal is sitting out
here at 1,0,0 one is sitting
at 0,1,0 one is sitting
at 0,0,1.
Even I can calculate the
mean of those three.
It's one third, one third,
an one third.
So you calculate the energy in
one third, one third, and one
third, and it's three times
one ninth, or one third.
Which is exactly
what this says.
The energy difference between
orthogonal and simplex is 1
minus 1 over m.
In other words that's the factor
in energy that you lose
by using orthogonal
codes instead of
using simplex codes.
Why do people ever use
orthogonal codes?
If it's just a pure loss
in energy in doing so?
Well, one reason is when n
gets up to be 6 or 8, it
doesn't amounts to
a whole lot.
And the other reason is if you
look at if you look at
modulating these things on to
sine waves and things like
that, you suddenly see that
when you're using this it
becomes easier to keep frequency
lock and phase lock
than it does when
you use this.
I mean you have to think about
that argument a little bit to
make sense out of it.
But that, in fact, is why people
often use orthogonal
signals because, in fact,
they can recover
other things from it.
Well because they're actually
sending a mean, also.
So the mean is the thing that
lets them recover all these
other neat things.
So that sort of sometimes
rules out this and it
sometimes rules out that.
OK.
Orthogonal and biorthogonal
codes have the same energy?
Well, look at them.
These two signal points each
have the same energy.
And these two have the same
energy as these two.
So the average energy
is the same as the
energy at each point.
So this and this have
the same energy.
What happens to the probability
of error?
Well you can't evaluate
it exactly.
Except here is a case where just
looking at the m equals 2
case gives you the
right answer.
I mean here to make an error
you have to go across that
boundary there.
Here to make an error you have
to either go across that
boundary or go across
that boundary.
The error of probability
essentially goes up by a
factor of two.
Same thing happens here.
You just get twice as
many ways to make
errors as you had before.
And all of these ways to make
errors are equally probable.
All the points are equally
distant from each other.
So you essentially just double
the number of likely ways you
can make errors.
And the error probability
essentially goes up by two.
Goes up a little--
well because you're using a
union band it either goes up
by a little more or a little
less than two--
but it's almost two.
OK, so I want to actually find
the probability of error now.
If you're sending an
orthogonal code.
Namely, we pick an orthogonal
code where we pick as many
code words as we want to.
m might be 64, it might
be 128, whatever.
And we want to try to figure
out how to evaluate the
probability of error for
this kind of code.
After you face the fact that,
in fact, these lines are not
orthogonal to each other.
OK, well the way you do this
is you say, OK the, even
though this is a slightly messy
problem, it's clear from
symmetry that you got the same
error probability no matter
which signal point you sent.
Namely, every signal point is
exactly the same as every
other signal point.
What you call the first signal
depends only on which you
happen to call the first
orthonormal direction.
Whether it's this,
or this, or this.
I can change it in anyway I
want to and the problem is
still exactly the same.
OK, so all I'm going to do
is try to find the error
probability when I send
this signal here.
In other words, when
I send 1,0,0--
actually I'm going to send the
square root of e and 0,0--
because I want to talk about
the energy here.
Why am I torturing
you with this?
Well 50 years ago, 55 years
ago, Shannon came out with
this marvelous paper which says
there's something called
channel capacity.
And what he said channel
capacity was
was the minimum rate--
the, was the maximum rate at
which you could transmit on a
channel and still get zero
error probability.
Sort of the simplest and most
famous case of that is where
you have white Gaussian
noise to deal with.
You're trying to transmit
through this
white Gaussian noise.
And you can use as much
bandwidth as you want.
Namely, you can spread
the signals out as
much as you want to.
You can sort of see from
starting to look at this
picture that you're going to
be a little better off, for
example, if you want to send
one bit in these two
dimensions here with
orthogonal signals.
If you can think of what happens
down here for m equals
4, you would wind up with
four orthogonal signals.
And if you wind up with four
orthogonal signals, you're
sending two bits, so you're
going to use twice as much
energy for each of them.
So you can scale each of
these up to be 2,0,0,0;
0,2,0,0; and so forth.
So you're sending twice
as much energy.
You're filling up more bandwidth
because you need
more degrees of freedom
to send this signal.
But who cares?
Because we have all the
bandwidth we want.
Gets more complicated.
But the question is, what
happens if we go to a very
large set of orthogonal
signals?
And what we're going to find is
that when we go to a very
large set of orthogonal signals,
we can get an error
probability which goes to zero
as the number of orthogonal
signals gets bigger.
It goes to zero very fast
as we send more
bits with each signal.
And the place where
it goes to zero is
exactly channel capacity.
Now in your homework, you're
going to work out a simpler
version of all of this.
And a simpler version
is something
called the union band.
And in the union band you just
assume that the probability of
error when you send this is the
sum of the probability of
error, of making an error, to
this and the possibility of
making an error to this.
The thing that we're
going to add here--
and let me try to explain
it from this picture.
I'm sending this point here.
OK?
And I can find the probability
of error over to that point.
Which is the probability of
going over that threshold.
I can talk about the probability
of error to over
here, which is the probability
of going over that threshold.
These are not orthogonal
to each other.
And in fact they have a common
component to them.
And the common component is
what happens in this first
direction here.
OK, in other words if you send
1,0,0 and the noise, and your
own noise variable
clobbers you.
In other words, what you receive
is something in this
coordinate which is way down
here and sort of arbitrary
everywhere else--
conditional on the noise here
being very, very large--
you're probably going
to make an error.
Now if you can imagine having a
million orthogonal signals--
and the noise clobbering you on
your own noise variable--
you're going to have a million
ways to make errors.
And they're all going to
be kind of likely.
If I go far enough down here,
suppose what I receive in this
coordinate is zero.
Then there's a probability of
one half that each one of
these things is going to
be greater than zero.
If I use a union bound, adding
up the probabilities of each
of these, I'm going to add
up a million one halves.
Which is 500,000.
As an upper bound to
a probability.
And that's going to clobber
my bound pretty badly.
Which says the thing I want to
do here is, when I'm sending
this I want to condition my
whole argument on what the
noise is in this direction.
And given what the noise is in
this direction, I will then
try to evaluate the
error probability,
conditional on this.
And conditional on a received
value here.
In fact, the noise in the
direction, w2, is independent
of the noise in direction, w3,
independent of the noise in
direction, w4, and so forth.
So at that point, condition on
w1 I'm dealing with m minus 1
independent random variables.
I can deal with independent
random variables.
You can deal with an independent
Maybe some of you can
integrate over
these complex polycons.
I can't.
I don't want to.
I don't want to write a
program that does it.
I don't want to be close to
anybody who writes a program
that does it.
It offends me.
OK, so here we go.
Where am I?
OK, so the first thing I'm going
to do, which I didn't
tell you, because I'm
going to scale the
problem a little bit.
I did say that here.
I'm going to normalize the whole
problem by calling my
output W sub j instead
of Y sub j.
And I'm going to normalize it by
multiplying Y sub j by the
square root of the
noise variance.
OK in other words, I'm going to
scale the noise down so the
noise has unit variance.
And by scaling the noise down
so it has unit variance, the
signal will be scaled down
in the same way.
So the signal, now, instead of
being the square root of e--
which is the energy I have
available-- it's going to be
the square root 2e
divided by N0.
Somehow this thing keeps
creeping up everywhere.
This 2e over N0.
Well of course it's the
difference between e, which is
the energy we have to send the
signal, and N0 over 2, which
is the noise energy in each
degree of freedom.
So it's not surprising
that it's sort of
a fundamental quantity.
And as soon as we normalize to
make the noise variance equal
to one, that's what
the signal is.
So I'm going to call alpha this
so I don't have to write
this all the time.
Because it gets kind of
messy on the slides.
OK so given that I'm going to
send input one, the received
variable W1 is going to be
normal with a mean alpha which
is the square root of 2e over N0
and with a variance of one.
All the other random variables
are going to be
normal random variables.
Mean zero, variance one.
OK?
I'm going to make an error if
any one of these other random
variables happens to rise
up and exceed W1.
So the thing we have here is W1
is doing some crazy thing.
I have this enormous sea of
other code words in other
directions.
And then the question we
ask is can the noise--
which is usually very small
all over the place but it
might rise up some place.
And if it rises up someplace,
we're asking what's the
probability that it's going to
rise up to be big enough that
it's exceeds W1?
So, I can at least write down
what the error probability is
exactly at that point.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to write down the
probability density for W1.
And W1, remember, is a Gaussian
random variable with
mean alpha and with
variance one.
So we could actually write down
what that density is.
And for each W1 I'm going to
make an error if the union of
any one of these
events occurs.
Namely, if any one of the
W sub j is bigger than
W1, bingo I'm lost.
OK?
So I'm going to integrate that
now over all values of W1.
Now, as I said before if W1 is
very small, then lots of other
signals look more
likely than W1.
In other words I'm going
to get clobbered no
matter what I do.
Whereas if W1 is large, it looks
like the union bound
might work here.
And the union bound is what
you're doing in the homework
without paying any
attention to W1.
OK, so I'm going to use the
union band-- and the union
band says the probability that
this union of all these
different m minus 1 events--
exceeds some value, W1.
W1 is just some arbitrary
constant in here.
The probability of this.
I'm going to write
it in two ways.
It's upper bounded by one.
Because all probabilities are
upper bounded by one.
This is not a probability
density, this is a probability
now so it's upper
bounded by one.
And it's also upper bounded
by this union band.
Mainly, the union of
m minus 1 events.
Each with probability.
This is the tail of the
Gaussian distribution
evaluated at w1.
So I have the union band here.
I have one here.
Going to pick some
parameter gamma.
I don't know what gamma should
be yet, but whatever I pick
gamma to be I still have
a legitimate bound.
This is less than or equal to
this, and it's less than or
equal to this.
Just common sense dictates that
I'm going to use this
when this is less than one.
And I'm going to use this when
this is greater than one.
That's what common sense says.
As soon as I start to evaluate
this, common sense goes out
the window because then I start
to deal with setting
this quantity equal to one and
dealing with the inverse of
the Gaussian distribution
function.
Which is very painful.
So I'm then going to
bound what this is.
And in terms of the bound on
this, I'm going to affect
gamma that way.
Because all I'm interested in
is an upper bound on error
probability anyway.
OK, so that's where
we're going to go.
So this probability of error
then is then exceeded by using
this bound for small W1.
I get this integral over
all W1 between minus
infinity and gamma.
And let's just look at
what this becomes.
This is just the tail of the
Gaussian distribution.
That's the lower tail instead
of the upper tail, but that
doesn't make any difference.
So this is exactly Q of
alpha minus gamma.
Mainly, alpha is where the mean
of this density is and
gamma is where I integrate to.
So if I shift the thing
down, I get
something that goes from--
well you might be surprised as
to why this is minus gamma
instead of plus gamma, and it's
minus gamma because I'm
looking at the lower tail rather
than the upper tail and
asking you to think this
through in real time is
unreasonable, but believe me
if you sit down and think
about it for a couple of seconds
you'll realize that
this integral is exactly this
lowered tail of this Gaussian
distribution.
The other term is a little
more complicated.
It's m minus 1, which is that
term there, times Q of w1,
which is this term here, times
the Gaussian density.
Now this is the Gaussian density
for W1, which is one
over square root of 2pi.
This is a normalized invariance,
but it has a mean
of alpha, so it's this.
OK, well next thing we have to
do is either fiddle around
like mad or look at this.
If you remember one of the
things that you did--
I think in the previous homework
that you passed in--
you found the bound on Q.
Which looks like this.
OK.
That's just the tail of the
Gaussian distribution.
And the tail of the Gaussian
distribution is upper banded
by this for W1 greater than
or equal to zero.
It's upper bounded by a bunch of
other things which you find
in this problem.
The other bounds are tighter.
This is the most useful bound
to the Gaussian distribution
that there is.
Because it works for W greater
than or equal to zero.
And it's exact when W1
is equal to zero.
Because you're just integrating
over half of the
Gaussian density.
And it's convenient and
easy to work with.
But what that says is the Q
of W1, when W1 is anything
greater than or equal to zero,
looks very much like a
Gaussian density.
So the thing that you're doing
here is taking one Gaussian
density and you're
multiplying it by
another Gaussian density.
And the one Gaussian density is
sitting here looking like
this with some scale factor
on it at zero.
The other Gaussian density
is out here at alpha--
was alpha, wasn't it?
Or was it gamma?
Can't keep my gammas and
alphas straight--
OK, and it looks like this.
If you take the product of two
Gaussian densities of the same
amplitude and everything.
And the same variance.
What do you wind up with?
Well you can go through and
complete the square.
And you can sort of see from
looking at this from the
symmetry of it that
what you're going
to get is the Gaussian.
Which is right there.
Alpha over 2.
OK so these two things,
when you multiply
them, look like this.
This has the same variance
as these two things do.
But it's centered
on alpha over 2.
If you want to take the Fourier
transform and multiply
the Fourier transform.
I mean, you take the Fourier
transform of the Gaussian and
you got a Gaussian.
So here we're multiplying.
Up there in Fourier transform
space you're convolving.
And when you convolve a Gaussian
with a Gaussian you
got a Gaussian.
When you multiply Gaussian by a
Gaussian you got a Gaussian.
When you do anything to a
Gaussian, you got a Gaussian.
OK?
So this thing--
and if you don't believe me just
actually take these two
exponents and complete the
square and see what you get--
so the mean is going
to be alpha over 2.
So, here you have a term which
is one tail of the Gaussian
distribution centered at
alpha minus gamma.
And here you have another one
centered at alpha over 2.
When you see these two terms,
something clicks in your mind
and says that sometimes this
term is going to be the
significant term.
Sometimes this term is going
to be significant term.
And it depends on
whether gamma--
alpha minus gamma- is
greater than or less
than alpha over 2.
So you can sort of see what's
going to happen right away.
Well I hope you can see what's
going to happen right away,
because I'm not going
to torture you
with any more of this.
And you can look at the notes
to find the details.
But you now sort of see
what's happening.
Because you have a
sum of two terms.
We're trying to upper
bound this.
We don't much care about factors
of two, or factors of
square root of 2pi
or anything.
We're trying to look at when
this goes to zero.
When you make m bigger
and bigger.
And when it doesn't
go to zero.
So when we do this, the
probability of error is going
to be less than or equal to
either of these two terms.
And here are these
two alternatives
that we spoke about.
Namely when alpha over 2 is less
than or equal to gamma,
we get this.
When alpha over 2 is greater
than gamma, we get this.
And this involves choosing gamma
in the right way, so
that that union bound is about
equal to one at gamma.
OK, well that doesn't
tell us anything.
So we say, "OK, what we're
really interested in here is,
as m is getting bigger and
bigger, we're spending a
certain amount of energy
per input bit.
And that's what we're interested
in as far as
Shannon's theorem
is concerned.
How much energy do you
spend to send a bit
through this channel?
And this gives you the answer
to that question.
You let log m equal to b. m
is the size of the signal
alphabet, so b is the number
of bits you're sending.
So Eb, namely the energy per
bit, is just the total energy
in these orthogonal waveforms
divided by b.
So that's the energy per bit.
OK, you substitute these two
things into that equation and
what you get is these
two different terms.
You got E to the minus
b times this junk.
And E to the minus b
times this junk.
What happens when m gets big?
When m gets big, holding Eb
fixed, so the game is we're
going to keep doubling our
orthogonal set, being able to
transmit one more bit.
And every time we transmit one
more bit, we get a little more
energy that we can use to
transmit that one extra bit.
So we used an orthogonal set,
but using a little more energy
in that orthogonal set.
So what this says is that the
probability of error goes down
exponentially with
b, if either one
these terms are positive.
And this, and looking at the
biggest of these terms tells
you which one you
want to look at.
So, anytime that Eb over 4N0 is
less than or equal to log n
is less than Eb over N0,
you get this term.
Any time Eb over 4N0 is greater
than the natural log
of 2, you get this term.
Now when you go through the
union bound in your homework,
I'll give you a clue.
This is the answer you
ought to come up with
when you're all done.
Because that's what the
union bound tells you.
Here, remember we did something
more sophisticated
the union bound because we said
the union bound is lousy
when you get a lot
of noise on W1.
And therefore we did something
separate for that case.
And what we're finding now is
depending on how much energy
we're using, namely depending on
whether we're trying to get
very, very close to channel
capacity or not.
If you're trying to get very
close to channel capacity
you've got to use this
answer here.
Which comes from here.
And in this case, this says that
the probability of error
goes to zero exponentially in
the number of bits you're
putting into this orthogonal
code, at this rate.
Eb over 2N0 minus log 2.
Which is positive if
Eb over 4N0, well--
I'm sorry.
If you can, if you can trace
back about three minutes, just
reverse everything I said about
this and about this.
Somehow I wrote these
inequalities in the wrong way
and it sort of confused me.
This is the answer you're
going to get
from the union bound.
This is the answer that we get
now because we use this more
sophisticated way of
looking at it.
Sob.
No.
Erase what I just said in the
last thirty seconds and go
back to what I said
before that.
This is the answer you're going
to get in the homework.
This is the answer that
we want to look at.
This thing goes--
is valid-- anytime that
Eb over N0 is
greater than or equal--
is greater than natural
log of 2.
When Eb over N0 is equal to log
2, that's the capacity of
this channel.
Namely Eb equals N0 log 2.
Well better to say it
Eb over N0 equals
natural log of 2 is capacity.
And anytime Eb over N0 is
greater than log 2 this term
in here is positive.
The error probability goes down
exponentially as b gets
large and eventually
goes to zero.
It doesn't get down as fast
here as it does here.
But this is where you really
want to be because this is
where you're transmitting with
absolutely the smallest amount
of energy possible.
OK, so that's Shannon's
formula.
And at least we have caught up
to 50 years behind what's
going on in communication.
And actually shown you something
that's right there.
And in fact, what we went
through today is really the
essence of that, of
the proof of the
channel capacity theorem.
If you want to do it for
finite bandwidth
it gets much harder.
But for this case,
we really did it.
It's all there.
I mean you read the notes and
in a little extra detail.
But just with the grunge
work left out, that's
what's going on.
OK, wireless communication.
That's what we want to spend
the rest of the term on.
We want to spend the rest of
the term on that because
whether you realize it or not,
we sort of said everything
there is to say about white
Gaussian noise.
And when all of that sinks in,
what you're left with is the
idea the white Gaussein noise.
You're really dealing with just
a finite vector problem.
And you don't have to worry
about anything else.
The QAM and the PAM, all that
stuff, all disappear.
Doesn't matter whether you send
things broadband, narrow
band, whatever.
It's all the same answer.
Wireless is different.
Wireless is different for
a couple of reasons.
You're dealing with the
radiation between antennas
because you're dealing with the
rather than what's going
on on a wire.
I mean, what's going on a wire,
the wire is pretty much
shielded from the
outside world.
So you send something, noise
gets added, and you receive
signal plus noise.
There's not much fading,
there's not much
awkward stuff going on.
Here all of the stuff goes on.
As soon as you start using
wireless communication, you're
allowed to drive around
in your car talking on
two phones at once.
With your ears and
eyes shielded.
You can kill yourself much
easier that way than you can
with ordinary telephony.
You can be in constant
communications with almost anyone.
OK, so you have motion, you
have temporary locations.
You have all these
neat things.
And if you look at what's
happening in the world, the
less developed parts of the
world have much more mobile
communication than we do.
Because in fact they don't
have that much wire
communication.
It's not that good there.
So they find it's far cheaper
to get a mobile phone.
Than like us where we have to
pay for both a wire line phone
and a mobile phone.
So they have sort of the best
of the two worlds there.
Except their mobile phones are
like our mobile phones.
They only work three quarters
of the time.
And all of the research that's
going into sending video over
wireless phones, it seems that
nobody's spending any time
trying to increase the amount
of time you can use your
wireless phone from
75% to 90%.
And if any of you want to make
a lot of money and also do
something worthwhile for the
world, invent a wireless phone
the works 90% of the time.
And you'll clean
up, believe me.
And you can even send video on
it later if you want to.
OK that's another thing that
wireless has turned out to be
very useful for.
And I'm sure you
all know this.
It avoids mazes of wires.
I mean many people in their
homes and offices and
everywhere are starting to use
local area wireless networks
just as a way of getting rid
of all of these maddening
wires that we have running
all over the place.
As soon as we have a computer
and a printer and a fax
machine and a blah blah blah,
and a watch which is connected
to our, and a toaster which is
connected to our computer.
Argh!
Pretty soon we're going to be
connected to our computers.
We're going to have little
things stuck in our head and
stuck our neck and all
over the place.
So it'll be nice to have these,
it'll be nice to not
have wires when we're
doing that.
OK, but the new problem is that
the channel, in fact,
changes with time.
It's very different from
one time to another.
And you get a lot of
interference between channels.
In other words, when you're
dealing with wireless you
cannot think of just
one transmitter and
one receiver anymore.
That's one of the problems
you want to think about.
But you really have to think
about what all the other
transmitters are doing and
what all the other
receivers are doing.
It was started by
Marconi in 1897.
It took him about three years
to get transcontinental
communication.
I mean we think we're
so great now--
being able to have research move
as quickly as it does--
but if you think of the amount
of time it takes to create a
new wireless system, it's
a whole lot larger
now than it was then.
I mean he moved very fast.
I mean the technology was very
primitive and very simple.
It was not a billion
dollar business.
But in fact it was
very, very rapid.
But what's happened since,
with wireless,
has been very fitful.
Businesses have started.
Businesses have stopped.
People have tried
to do one thing.
People have tried to
do another thing.
They name things by something
different all the time.
I mean one sort of amusing thing
is back in the early
seventies the army was trying
very hard to get wireless
communication in the field.
And they called this
packet radio.
And they had all the
universities in the country
spending enormous amounts of
time developing packet radio.
Writing many papers about it.
They finally got disgusted
because nothing was happening.
So they pulled all the
funding for that.
And about five years later, when
the people at DARPA and
NSF and all of that forgot
about this unpleasant
experience, people started
talking about ad hoc networks.
Guess what an ad
hoc network is?
Same thing as packet radio.
Just a new name for an old
system, and suddenly the money
started flowing in again.
We don't know whether it'll be
any better this time than it
was last time.
But anyway that's the
way funding goes.
OK, what we're going to talk
about in this class is sort of
an old fashioned thing.
It's not as sexy as what all
these other systems are.
It's just cellular networks.
It's probably because that's
well understood by now, and
it's because we can talk about
all of these fundamental
problems that occur in mobile
communication just in the
context of this one kind of
system that, by now, is
reasonably well understood.
When you're doing cellular
communication, you wind up
with a large bunch of mobiles
all communicating with one
base station.
OK, in other words you don't
have the kind of thing you had
in the packet radio network or
in the ad hoc network, where
you have a huge number of mobile
telephones which are
all communicating
to each other.
And where one phone has to
relay things for others.
You wind up with a very
complicated network problem.
Here, it's in a sense,
a much simpler
and more sane structure.
Because you're using mobile
for doing the things that
mobile does well.
And you're using wires
for the things that
wires do very well.
Mainly you have lots of mobiles
which are moving all
over the place.
You have these fixed base
stations which are big and
expensive, and put up on hills
or on buildings or on big
poles or something.
And you spend a lot
of money on them.
You have optical fibers or
cables or what have you
running between them or running
from them to what's
called a MTSO.
Mobile Something Subscriber
Office-- and I can never
remember what those letters
stand for--
Mobile Telephone Subscriber
Office.
All I had to do to remember that
was thank this was done
by telephone engineers.
No, Mobile Telephone Switching
Office and telephone engineers
think in terms of switching and
in terms of telephones.
And mobile and offices
just follows along.
So the way these systems work
is you go from a mobile to a
base station.
From the base station to one of
these MTSOs, which is just
a big switching center.
From there you're in
the wired network.
And from there you can either go
back to a mobile or go back
to a wire line telephone or
go anywhere you want to.
But but the point in that, and
I think this is important to
remember, is that cellular
networks are an appendage of
the wire line network.
And you always have this wire
line network in the middle.
You probably always will.
Because wire line networks have
things like fiber which
carries enormous amounts of
data very, very cheaply.
And mobile is very limited
as far as capacity goes.
And it's very noisy.
OK, so that lets us avoid
the question of
how do you do relaying.
When you see pictures of this,
people draw pictures of
hexagon cells.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
turn around.
PROFESSOR: Oh, when I hit
this, and it uh, OK.
I mean there's not much
information on this picture
anyway but, [LAUGHTER]
OK, but people think in terms
of base stations put down
uniformly with nice hexagons
around them.
And any time a mobile within
one hexagon it communicates
with the base station which is
at the center of that hexagon.
And in reality what happens is
that the base stations are
spread all over the place
in a very haphazard way.
I shouldn't say haphazard,
because people worked very
hard to find places to put
these base stations.
Because you need to rent real
estate, or buy real estate to
put them in.
You have to find out somehow
what kind of
coverage they have.
And it's a very fascinating and
very difficult problem.
One thing I'm going to try to
convince you of in the next
lecture or so is that the
problems of choosing base
stations are very heavily
electromagnetic in nature.
You really have to understand
electromagnetism very well.
And and you have to understand
the modeling of these physical
communication links very, very
well in order to try to sort
out where base stations
should go and where
they shouldn't go.
The other part of the problem
is the part of the problem
dealing with how do you design
the mobile phone itself?
How do you design the
base station itself?
And these are questions which
don't depend so much on the
exact modeling of the
electromagnetic channel.
They only depend on very coarse
characteristics of it.
And very often, when you start
to study mobile, you will
spend an inordinate amount of
time studying all of the
details of these electromagnetic
channels.
Which in fact are very important
as far as choosing
base stations are concerned.
And have relatively little to
do with the questions of how
do you design mobiles.
How do you design
base stations?
It has enough to do with it
that you have to know
something about it, but it's
not central anymore.
OK, so let's look at what
the problems are.
As I said the cellular network
is really an appendage to the
wire network.
The problems we're going to
have to deal with is when
you're outgoing from your own
cell phone, there's some kind
of strategy that has to be used
for you to find the best
base station to use.
And it's a difficult question
because you're trying to find
a base station you can
communicate with and one
that's not so overcrowded that
you can't talk to it.
So that's one big problem.
We won't talk about that much.
Another is the ingoing
problem.
Finding a mobile.
If you think about that, it's
really a very tricky problem.
Because I run around in my car
with my cellphone turned off
all the time.
And I only turn it on if I
want to talk to somebody.
So I turn it on and somehow
the whole network has to
suddenly realize where I am.
And you know that happens with
all of these cellular networks
all over the place.
And every time somebody turns on
their cell phone there's a
lot of stuff going back
and forth that
says who is this guy?
Does he have the
right to talk?
Has he paid is bill?
And how do I actually find a
base station for him to use?
So this is kind of, both these
questions are kind of difficult.
And the even worse question is
if somebody's calling me and I
live say, in Boston, or close to
Boston, and I'm out in San
Francisco and somebody calls me
on my cell phone, the call
gets to me.
And if you just imagine a little
bit what has to go on
in this cellular network in
order for the cellular network
to realize that I'm in San
Francisco instead of Boston.
And then realize how to get
calls to me in San Francisco.
I mean there's a lot
of interesting
stuff going on here.
But we're not going to talk
about any of that because
that's really sort of an
organizational question as
opposed to a physical
communication question, which
is the kind of thing we're
interested in here.
OK, when you have these multiple
mobiles which are
sending to the same
base station.
People who are working on mobile
communication, sort of
the practical side of it, call
this the reverse channel.
Why they call this the reverse
channel and the other one the
forward channel, I don't know.
Forward channel goes from the
base station to the mobile.
Reverse station, reverse channel
goes from the mobile
to the base station.
And what it says is the
terminology was chosen by the
people designing the
base stations.
That's sort of clear.
But if you read about this
in any more technical
publication, you will see this
thing being called a multi
access channel.
It's the multi access channel
because many, many users are
all trying to get into the
same base station.
And this one electromagnetic
wave-- which is impinging on
the various space station
antennas-- is carrying all of
that stuff all multiplexed
together in some way.
And it's not multiplexed
together in a sensible way,
because it's multiplexed
together just by all of these
waveforms randomly adding
to each other.
So information theorists
call these things
multi access channels.
When you're going the other way,
base station to mobiles,
it's called the forward
channel by
the telephone engineers.
It's called the broadcast
channel
by information theorists.
For those of you who think about
broadcast in terms of TV
and FM and all that sort
of stuff, this is
a little bit confusing.
Because this is not the same
kind of broadcast that you're
usually thinking about.
I mean the usual kind of
broadcast is where everybody
gets the same thing whether
you want it or not.
But that whole signal is there,
and you all get the
whole thing.
Here what it is, is
you're sending a
different message to everyone.
You don't want everyone to be
able to tune in and receive
what anybody else is getting.
You want a little
privacy here.
So it's really broadcasting
separate messages and trying
to keep them separate.
While the systems, almost
all of them, are
now digital I think.
In the sense of having a binary
interface, this is the
same issue we've been talking
about all along.
You say something is digital
if there's the binary
interface on it.
The source is either
analog or digital.
Cellular communication was
really designed for voice.
Now all the research is
concerned with how do you make
it work for data also.
One of the things we're going to
talk about a little bit is
why the problems are
so very different.
I mean you would think they're
both the same problem.
Because in both cases
you're just
transmitting a string of bits.
That's all that's going on.
But the big difference is that
in voice, you can't tolerate
delay in voice.
In data you can tolerate
delay.
You can tolerate a lot
of delay in data.
And therefore you can do lots
of things with data that you
can't do with voice.
If you want to have a system
that deals with both voice and
data, it's got to be able
to get the voice
through without delay.
And you have to find some way
of solving that problem.
OK, let me just say
this quickly.
Let me just see if there's
anything else of content here.
This is all just boiler
plate stuff.
Let me skip that.
And skip this.
The thing we're going to be
concerned about here is really
these physical modeling
issues.
And where we wind up with that
is we're typically talking
about bandwidths that are maybe
a few megahertz wide.
Maybe a few kilohertz wide.
Or maybe a few megahertz.
But we're talking about carrier
frequencies which are
usually up in the
gigahertz range.
And they keep varying depending
on which new range
of frequencies gets opened up.
They started out a little
below a gigahertz.
They only went up to 2.4
and now they're up
around five or six.
And things like that.
When we talk about physical
modeling, we want to
understand what difference
it makes what carrier
frequency you're at.
And it does make a difference
because we'll talk about
Doppler shift.
And Doppler shift changes a lot
as you go from one range
to another.
But for the most part these
systems are narrow band.
There's a lot of work now
on wide band systems.
And what's does a
wide band mean?
Does it mean more than
a megahertz?
No, it means a system where
the bandwidth that you're
communicating over is a
significant fraction of the
carrier frequency.
If there is a carrier
frequency.
Many of these wide band systems
are not even done in
terms of the carrier
frequency.
They're just done in terms of
an arbitrary waveform which
takes over an enormous
amount of bandwidth.
If you're dealing with the
narrow band problems, white
Gaussian noise is a good
assumption for the noise.
But now, along with
the noise you have
all these other effects.
You have a channel, where the
channel is not just a pass
through wire with a little
attenuation on it.
I mean, remember what we've
done all along.
We have absolutely ignored the
question of attenuation.
We've just gotten rid of it and
say what you send is what
you receive.
We've gotten rid of
the problem of
filtering on the channel.
We've said a little bit about
it, but essentially we've
avoided it.
Now the problem that you have
is this channel that you're
transmitting over really
comes and goes.
Sometimes it's there,
sometimes it's not.
So it's a time varying
channel.
It's a time varying channel
which depends on the frequency
band that we're using.
And one of the things that we
have to talk about in order to
come to grips with this is
questions about how quickly
does it change and why
does it change.
And how much do you have to
change the frequency before
you got something that looks
like an independently
different channel?
So we have to deal with both of
those and we're going to do
that next time.
And in trying to come to grips
with these questions, the
first thing we're going to do
is to look at very, very
idealized models of what goes
on in communication.
Like, we're going to
look at a point
source radiating outwards.
We're going to look at a point
source radiating outwords,
hitting a barrier,
and coming back.
Interesting problem to look at
and you ought to read the
notes about this.
What happens when you're in a
car and you're driving at 60
miles an hour towards
the reflecting wall.
And right before you hit
the wall, what's the
communication look like?
OK, that's a very neat and
very simple problem.
You can't do it many times,
but we will talk
about that next time.